bienvenue pour une nouvelle édition du
78 lactu le journal de la rédaction de
TV fil 78 nous sommes le 16 mai voici
les principaux titres et si la ville de
demain s'inspirait de la nature c'est le
Paris de velis ville coublet qui pour la
2uxè année propose exposition et
conférence sur ce thème une ville qui
recycle une ville qui fonctionne aux
énergies renouvelables les explications
à suivre en plateau du chargé de mission
Développement durable de la commune il
nonont que quelques semaines pour
convaincre les candidats aux européennes
multiplient les réunions et les
événements sur le terrain retour sur les
derniers meetings organisés dans les
ivelines au cours de ce journal et puis
comme chaque vendredi nous revenons sur
l'actualité de la semaine actualité
marquée par ce bras de fer presque sans
fin autour des rythme scolaire le
directeur académique des services de
l'éducation nationale met en garde les
mairies aujourd'hui rétis
pour débuter une bonne nouvelle si vous
appréciez le 9e les plus grandes maisons
d'édition associé pour lancer les 48hur
de la BD à travers toute la France mais
aussi la Belgique 100000 albums
distribués gratuitement aujourd'hui
vendredi et samedi la librairie le pavé
du canal à montiné le bretonne participe
notamment torgal Batman ou encore Alix
vous seront offerts sur simple demande
et c'est sans obligation d'achat c'est
toujours important de le préciser on va
à présent s'intéresser donc à la ville
de demain avec notre invité Guillaume
Porcheron bienvenue sur ce
chargé de mission Développement Durable
à véis ville coublet pour la deuxème
fois vous proposez conférence exposition
sur le biomimétisme alors avant de vous
laisser nous expliquer en quoi cela
consiste on va écouter quelques
ivelinois l'occasion était rêvé d'aller
leur demander ce qu'était la
biomimétique selon eux mimé c'est
ressemblé à quelqu'un
ça je sais pas autrement je vois pas o
il le revenenir avec ça là ça ressemble
à une autre ville il y a le terme bio
hein
donc écologique quelque part et
mimétique c'est c'est dans le dans le
comportement une ville bio peut-être ou
ou on fait très attention à la à tout
aux ordures à l'eau à tout une ville qui
soit à la fois verte et mimétique je
sais pas ce que c'est le mimétisme donc
c'est une ville qui donnerait l'exemple
sur sur son
comportement écologiste on n pas loin de
tout ça un petit peu il y a quelques
éléments une ville biomimétique c'est
quoi alors en effet il y a il y a
quelques quelques éléments justes une
ville biomimétique c'est une ville qui
s'inspire du vivant de la nature
étymologiquement le mot bios veut dire
en grec vie mimésis imité donc c'est
imiter la vie voilà et dans ce mot-là il
y a une dimension durable en faitin
c'est ve dire comment imiter la vie pour
faire des des produits des services
innovants mais d'une manière durable
voilà ça a été théorisé en 1997 par une
scientifique américaine qui s'appelle
Janine benus et euh voilà c'est comment
imiter la vie mais euh en faisant euh en
ayant un modèle un modèle de
développement plus durable quelles
applications concrètes alors il y en a
des des milliers des milliards des enfin
bref euh un exemple simple pour qu'on
comprenne alors l'exemple un des
exemples les plus connus c'est quand on
s'inspire de de de de la forme euh par
exemple du martin pêcheur le le TGV
japonais le chikanzen euh reprend
strictocensu la forme du bec et du et et
du du crâne du martin pêcheur pour son
taux de pénétration optimale dans l'air
et dans l'eau grâce à cela ce TGV peut
rentrer dans les tunnels euh sans qu'il
y ait trop de de
euh en rentrant plus facilement dans ces
tunnels euh sans qu'il y ait trop de
frottement ils consomment moins
d'énergie ils vont plus vite qu'un TGV à
moteur équivalent donc on s'inspire déjà
depuis plusieurs années de de de ce que
fait la nature de la façon dont évolue
la la nature mais seulement depuis
quelques années là c'est la seconde
édition c'est la deuxè édition de de
votre opération on s'intéresse aux
applications pour la ville pour le
quotidien pour tous les jours c'est
assez récent cette idée c'est c'est
c'est c'est très novateur j'ai j'ai
envie de dire le la ville biométique en
fait n'existe pas euh alors peut presque
dire qu'on a inventé le terme euh donc
c'est vraiment repenser la ville en fait
en s'inspirant du vivant c'estàd qu'on a
sous nos yeux on a 3,8 milliards
d'années de recherche et développement
ça c'est c'est voilà c'est la nature qui
a toujours
créé des des des des éléments des
système pour être en équilibre constant
voilà comment on peut s'inspirer de ça
et comment on peut appréhender la ville
d'une manière globale en s'inspirant du
vivant c'est faire avec le vivant avec
la nature et non pas contre comme on le
faisait continuellement alors en terme
d'application concrète bah c'est c'est
des des nouvelles typologies de de
bâtiment c'est un urbanisme repensé
c'est c'est déjà quelque chose qui se
fait à véis ou pas à véisie pas encore
parce qu'on voilà c'est la c'est la
deuxème édition cet événement nous sert
un à je dirais démocratiser un peu le
sujet de c'est un laboratoire d'idées
pour nous et donc en effet on au sein de
la mairie on on on essaie de je dirais
de créer un cahier des charargge de ce
que peut être une ville biomumétique
appliqué à véisie
et en terme d'application concrète on va
en voir les je dirais les premiers
résultats dans les dans les années qui
viennent notamment pour un quartier le
quartier Louvois qui un quartier en
plein renouvellement urbain où on
détruit une dalle de 3 hectares on
retrouve donc la le le sol naturel et on
il y a va y avoir plusieurs milliers de
mètres carrés d'espace public à recréer
on a demandé à des étudiants de de
l'école
tekoma proche de chez nous l'école
l'environnement et du cadre de vie de
réfléchir à à ces aménagements là on
leur a le cahier décharge était assez
simple c'était de leur dire comment
reconnecter ce quartier à la forê for
comment faire pénétrer la forêt dans le
quartier comment favoriser une
biodiversité des plus riches euh sachant
que ces endroits seront partagés par
l'homme et la nature ils nous ont fait
des propositions très intéressantes
qu'on présente en partie dans cette
exposition et ensuite ce sera soumis au
public lors d'un débat public avec les
habitants on définira ensemble le le
quartier dans lequel il veut vivre
inspiré des grandes lois du vivant mais
faire du biomimétisme est-ce que ça
coûte plus cher aussi c'est un
engagement à prendre mais c'est
absolument hors de prix je plaisante euh
non çaurit pu euh alors il peut y avoir
des des surcouts mais j' dirais comme
tout mais en fait il faut réfléchir
cooupt global c'est-à-dire que peut-être
par exemple si on fait une façade euh
une biofaçade avec des microalgues euh
elle coûtera plus cher évidemment que
une façade classique euh cependant tous
les bénéfices qu'on en retire euh fait
que euh un ça samortira assez vite et
puis après il y a y a tous les bénéfices
j' dirais immatériel hein que que l'on
peut que l'on peut en avoir donc il faut
raisonner coup global
là ce sont des conférences des une
exposition qui ouvre d'ailleurs dès
aujourd'hui vendredi pour le grand
public vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure ce
mot c'est démocratisé on ne fait pas de
l'élitisme avec cette cette opération
sur véis c'estàdire que les gens
viennent vous voir de d'autres communes
aussi pour éventuellement s'inspirer de
ces idéesl alors tout à fait l'année
dernière pour le premier
événement on a eu la chance voilà il y a
eu des des Belges sont venus des gens de
de de différentes régions de France donc
c'est déjà rien que pour la première
édition ça a draîné du du des gens qui
venaient d'ailleurs que véisy je pense
que ça sera aussi le cas pour cette
deuxème édition et puis surtout on a la
chance de faire venir des des
conférenciers je dirais de haut vol avec
des architectes très prometteurs des
chercheurs aussi donc ce sera
extrêmement intéressant et ça devrait
attirer du monde exemple de conférence
le 21 mai 18h30 au théâtre de Londres
peut-on améliorer la ville grâce aux
toiles d'araignées par exemple voilà
exactement comment on ferait pour
améliorer une ville avec la ville avec
avec une toile d'araignée alors là on
est on est encore un peu dans la
recherche fondamentale mais c'est en
gros comment la ville peut s'inspirer
des toiles d'araignées orbitales
c'est-à-dire cette forme un peu un peu
ronde un peu en forme de cercle pour
améliorer ces réseaux de transport ces
réseaux aussi pour conduire bah les tous
les flux énergétiques et cetera euh
voilà parce qu'on sait chercheurs
notamment qui travaillent dessus Didier
Jocelin s'est rendu compte que les
villes médiévales notamment la ville
d'Avignon reprenaient sans le avir en
fait ces formes orbitelles voilà et
comment repenser la ville pour qu'elle
soit beaucoup plus efficace dans ces
modes de déplacement voilà ville
biomimétique ville de demain c'est à
véisie les renseignements pratiques qui
s'affichent et vous aurez aussi sur les
différents renseignements sur les
différentes conférences sur le site
Internet de votre commune c'est la
deuxème année c'est installée
durablement à véis vill coublet cette
cette opération l'exposition ou le
l'exposition renouveler chaque année ah
oui
oui notre objectif c'est de la
renouveler chaque année et puis ben
écoutez à chaque fois de grandir un peu
plus d'aborder de nouveaux sujets et
cetera mais en tout cas on aborde la
ville j' dirais d'une manière la plus
exhaustif possible on parle d'urbanisme
on parle d'architecture on parle de
nature en ville on parle de transport et
cetera et cetera merci Guillaume
Porcheron chargé de mission
Développement Durable à vellisie ville à
coublé d'être venu nous parler donc de
cette opération autour de la ville
biomimétique merci à vous le 78 lactu se
poursuit
l'Europe au cœur de nos préoccupations
et pour cause nous devrons voter dans
une semaine pour nos représentants au
Parlement représentants qui liront
ensuite pour la première fois un
président les conséquences des décisions
européennes sur la vie de ses
ressortissants sont importantes exemple
avec la mise en place d'une carte de
santé valable dans l'ensemble des pays
membres afin de simplifier le parcours
de soins cette possibilité n'est pas
toujours très connue et pourtant elle
est proposée depuis une dizaine d'années
yolen Torz et LOD
moine bonjour madame Mame besoin d'une
carte européenne pour partir en Crète
s'il vous plaît oui vous avez votre
carte Vitale s'il vous plaît l'été
approche les vacances aussi et si vous
avez décider de partir en Europe
n'oubliez pas d'emporter votre carte
européenne d'assurance maladie une carte
gratuite qui permet la prise en charge
financière de vos soins en Europe
autrement dit si vous tombez malade lors
de votre séjour vous n'aurez aucune
avance de frais à faire vous serez
directement remboursé sur place par
l'assurance maladie du pays concerné
attention toutefois tous les types de
soins ne sont pas pris en compte la
carte européenne assurance maladie
permet la prise en charge des soins qui
sont médicalement nécessaires et qui
sont non programmés ça concerne tous les
soins qui sont inopiné c'estàdire qu'une
rage de dent elle est pas prévue elle
peut être prise en charge en revanche
les soins qui sont programmés en amont
du départ dans le pays européen ne
seront pas pris en charge pour cela
procurer il suffit de faire une demande
en composant le 36 46 vous pouvez
également la commander via ses bornes
dans les accueils ou auprès d'un
conseiller de chez soi c'est également
possible en se con connectant sur le
site Internet
www.amélie.fr via un compte donc le
compte Amélie en fait c'est un compte
personnel qui est gratuit et qui est
sécurisé qui permet aux assurés de
consulter leur remboursement en temps
réel et qui offre une palette de
services en ligne comme l'impression
d'intation de droit et également la
commande de la carte européenne en cas
de départ imminent un certificat
provisoire de la carte européenne sera
nécessaire ce certificat est valable 3
mois la carte européenne d'assurance
maladie valable un an est individuelle
et nominative chaque membre de la
famille doit l'avir y compris les
enfants de moins de 16 ans prévoyez une
dizaine de jours avant de la recevoir
chez vous voilà madame merci au revoir
au
revoir et cette carte est donc le
valable dans 27 États-membres en Islande
au litenstein encore en Norvège mais
également en Suisse l'Europe côté
politique maintenant avec la campagne et
le scrutin proportionnel qui motive les
formations même les plus petites à
s'engager pour faire connaître leurs
idées et pourquoi pas gagner un siège
pour le Parlement en Île-de-France 15
postes d'eurodéputés sont à pourvoir
parmi les 74 au niveau national exemple
de ces petites formations avec nous
citoyens qui regroupe des gens de la
société civile frustrés distil de
l'incapacité des partis de gouvernement
à faire avancer les choses il présent
des listes dans l'ensemble des
circonscriptions françaises et viennent
de tenir une réunion publique dans les
Yvelines à hencour parmi leurs priorités
leurs neuf priorités emploi éducation
lutte contre l'exclusion et
particularité ce sont les électeurs qui
construisent le programme notamment via
le site Internet
je crois qu'il faut être effectivement
ambitieux et nous avons confiance parce
qu'on on le voit bien quand nous
tractons par exemple n donons des
tractes sur la voie publique et bien
beaucoup de gens se disent ah mais oui
Denis perère on l'a entendu on l'a vu à
la télévision en particulier et donc
nous avons tout à fait confiance
n'oublions pas quand même que sur les 74
élus qui sont réservé donc à la France
sur les
751 dans tout le Parlement européen il y
en a 15 pour la région Île-de-France ça
veut dire qu'il faut être ambitieux mais
il faut pas non plus se faire
d'illusion propos recueilli par Olivier
Manis calco est en cours encore sonné
par le résultat des derniers municipal
le Parti socialiste repart en campagne
la tête de l'IST Île de France pervanche
perz et son colistier Guillaume Ballas
viennent de se rendre au
Murau convaincre mot d'ordre des
socialistes pour se scrutin européen
convaincre sur le programme bien sûr
mais aussi sur le fait que l'élection ne
doit pas servir à sanctionner le
gouvernement fr ce scrutin c'est pas le
3è tour des municipales c'est pas un
sondage grandeur nature où on se fait
plaisir sans regarder quel est le
pouvoir qu'on met en place et ça n'est
pas non plus une mini présidentielle
dans un département comme celui-ci celui
des ivelines si on coupe les frontières
si on sort la France de l'euro si on
veut isoler la France et bien nous
perdrons des emplois parce que dans un
départ comme celui-ci beaucoup des
emplois dépendent d'entreprises qui sont
venu investir dans notre pays présente
au Mureau mercredi dernier la tête de
liste socialiste en Île-deFrance était
accompagné de ses colistiers Guillaume
Balas déjà conseiller régional et Michel
christofou seul Yv linoise recencé tout
deux préfèrent garder la tête froide
face au sondages qui donnent leur
formation 3e derrière le FN et l'UMP les
sondages municipal don un bon score pour
le Parti socialiste on a vu le résultat
donc j'allais dire pour plaisanter que
puisquils sont mauvais dat qu'on fera un
bon score non ça m' diffère totalement
ce qui est important c'est l'umilité les
sondages sont une photographie ça n'est
pas une prévision et donc c'est
bougeable 60 % des des personnes en
France son des soit ne connaissent pas
l'orientation politique du Parlement
européen soit pense qu'il est à gauche
donc c'est quand même extraordinaire de
de finalement d'avoir à assumer nous
socialistes français un Parlement
européen qui est majoritairement à
droite et largement une commission
européenne qui est majoritairement à
droite incarné par son président sur le
fond le PS évoque dans son programme un
salaire minimum européen une
harmonisation du droit des travailleurs
une taxation de la finance ou encore des
investissements dans de grands projets
industriels
illustration de cette déception des
électeurs socialistes la présence à ce
scrutin européen et travers toute la
France de la formation nouvelle donne
une formation politique lancée en
novembre dernier par le conseiller
régional pierre larouurou en désaccord
avec le Parti socialiste qu'il a
d'ailleurs quitté il est lui-même tête
de liste en
Île-de-France nouvelle donne pour faire
écho au New Deal de Roosevelt pour
Pierre Larouturou fondateur de ce
nouveau partis il faut aujourd'hui
réviser la fiscalité réduire le temps de
travail afin de créer de nouveaux
emplois tête de liste européenne en
île-de-fance c'est le message qu'il est
venu faire passer lors de son meeting à
l'université de versailles- SaintQuentin
nous à nou bal dononne on ne se résigne
pas on montre qu'il a des solutions il y
a pas de baguette magique mais si on
avait en même temps une autre politique
européenne une autre politique du
logement une autre façon de financer les
PME une autre façon de lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique une autre
répartition du temps de travail tout au
long de la vie si on donnait des plus de
travail aux PME si on réserver une
partie des commandes publiques pour les
PME il y a 15 propositions concrètes
pour montrer qu'on peut sortir du
chômage la formation entend prendre le
dessus sur le PS aux élections un
objectif ambitieux aujourd'hui 2 % des
électeurs auraient l'intention de voter
pour elle je pense que le PS est mort
depuis 2002 il n'ont plus aucune idée
neuve il y a eu aucun moment de
réflexion ils sont arrivés au là je suis
allé 15 fois à l'Élysée 15 fois à
Matignon depuis de an a du collectif
Roosevelt même Jean-Marc HUD me disit il
y a un an qu'il ne pouvait plus de
l'inertie de François Hollande sur
l'Europe même Jean-Marc hraud disait
qu'il ne croyait plus du tout au
discours sur la croissance je pense que
le PS il y a des gens très bien parmi
les élus locaux mais je crois
qu'intellectuellement il n'apporte plus
rien au pays et même il aggrave la crise
et les personnalités de plus en plus
nombreuses à soutenir nouvelles donnees
notamment l'acteur réalisateur ivelinois
Sam Caran on a un président autiste qui
fait une politique de droite qui qui ne
se bat pas et qui nous fait croire que
toujours les mêmes rang
il faut la croissance et pour faire la
croissance il faut faire confiance au
patronat il faut le leur faire des
machins et c'est eux qui vont créer de
l'emploi alors on sait que non le slogan
travailler plus pour gagner plus c'est
de la connerie voilà c'est tout c'est
organis organisonsnous pour partager le
travail car la croissance ne reviendra
pas c'est à partir de ce constat lucide
qu'il faut réfléchir du programme de
nouvelle donne on retiendra son ambition
de changer rapidement les choses un à 2
ans peuvent suffire pour construire une
autre
selon les fondateurs du
mouvement 31 listes se présentent en
île-de-fance pour ces européennes un
record battu alors que l'abstention
devrait être très forte l'UMP entend
bien surfer sur la vague de contestation
à l'encontre du gouvernement sortant
reste qu'actuellement monté du Front
National et division interne complique
un peu la campagne nous étions au
meeting mené par la tête de liste
alanamassour Mar leeroi le reportage
dans l'ouverture même que représente
notre famille politique qu l'UMP au-delà
de la famille politique de l'UMP
soutenait ala lamassour en île-defance
l'union de l'UMP derrière le candidat
lamassour en île-de-fance le message
adressé lors du meeting de marlie Leroi
par le sénateur Gérard Larcher éclair un
message repris un peu plus tard dans la
soirée par Valérie pcrè chef de fil de
la formation dans le département et qui
entend mettre fin à la polémique lancée
par le député Henry Gueno l'ancienne
pluB de Nicolas Sarkozi je ne
soutiendrai pas la campagne de Monsieur
lamassour je ne voterai pas pour
incntion d'une ligne qui est à l'opposé
non seulement de ce que je pense mais de
ce que je crois être l'intérêt de mon
pays écoutez c'est son
problème moi ce que je constate c'est
que l'UMP est totalement uni sur le
projet européen que nous avons mis au
point entre tous les dirigeants de l'UMP
depuis 4 mois maintenant alors que le
sujet européen a fait exploser le Parti
socialiste eurodéputé sortant de la
circonscription du Sud-Ouest Alan
lamassour entend surtout concentrer ses
efforts sur son principal rival le Front
national de parti au coude à coude dans
les sondages Madame Le Pen a au moins le
mérite de ne pas cacher son jeu son
slogan c'est détruire l'Europe votez
pour moi je vais détruire l'Europe or je
sais que beaucoup de Français qui ont
ralbol qui veulent exprimer un
mécontentement à la limite qui veulent
dire merde ne veulent pas détruire
l'Europe ce que nous voulons nous UMP
notre famille politique PPE AC la CDO
allemande c'est changer ce qui va mal en
Europe et utiliser l'Europe nous servir
de l'Europe l'Europe ne su que si on ne
s'en sert pas axe principal du programme
de l'UMP faire une Europe à géométrie
variable par exemple sur les questions
d'immigration en négociant avec les
états du nord de la Méditerranée ou
encore dans le domaine du nucléaire en
se rapprochant du Royaume-Uni et de la
Finlande et pour relayer ses idées dans
les ivelines Jean-Michel Fourgous mer
des lancour 7e sur la liste UMP en 2009
l'UMP était arrivé en tête en
Île-de-France raflant C sièges au
Parlement le myting du Front national à
présent dans les ivelines toujours ce
mardi soir au chînet devant une salle
comble de plus de 350 personnes le chef
de fil pour l'île de France Emeric
choprade est venu dire non à l'Union
européenne telle qu'elleexiste
actuellement la présence de la nièce de
Marine Le Pen Marion maréchal Le Pen
également député venu appeler les
électeurs à se mobiliser Catherine
zulato et Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
c'est une tête de liste nouvellement
engagé en politique qui se présente pour
animer la liste Front national en
île-de-fance pour les prochaines
élections européennes ééic choprade
géopoliticien se dit nourri de ses
réflexions et de ses expériences le
système de l'Union européenne
aujourd'hui ne fonctionne pas on a
aujourd'hui un bilan très clair sur le
plan économique sur le plan géopolitique
je le disais et qui fait que nous
n'avons pas construit d'Europe puissance
et qu'il y a une désindustrialisation
qu'il y a une perte de compétitivité de
la France de rang économique qu'il y a
des problèmes d'identité il faut euh
reconstruire l'Europe sur des bases de
respect des souverainetés entre les
états de spécifique ité de chaque nation
cette nouvelle Europe à construire le
Front national ne peut le faire qu'avec
l'apport des voix de ses électeurs un
électorat qui reste volatile c'est la
nièe de Marine Le Pen qui bat le rappel
nous avons un électorat qui est dit
c'est le terme des experts
sociologiquement abstenstionnistes on
parle en particulier des jeunes et des
classes populaires donc c'est vrai que
il y a un enjeu particulier ceux qui
pensent condamner la construction
européenne par l'abstention se trompe en
réalité l'abstention c'est le blanc sain
au grand mouvement en place uMPP
pour ces élections le secrétaire
départemental du Front national Philippe
Chevrier candidat également en
Île-de-France a fixé ses objectifs
obtenir à 20 % des suffrages sur les 74
députés français élus au Parlement
européen trois portent la couleur du
Front national sous l'étiquette des
noninscrits car tout l'enjeu aussi pour
le parti frontiste c'est de pouvoir
constituer un groupe au niveau européen
ce qui n'est pas le cas
actuellement européenne toujours et les
jeunes communistes qui s'engagent dans
la campagne ils étaient à ans en Eveline
cette semaine pas de meeting une
distribution de tract dans les rues de
l'agglomération comme ici non loin de
l'avenue du centre à montinil Bretonneux
de message fort l'Europe doit être une
institution de solidarité internationale
notamment en prenant la reconnaissance
de l'État palestinien le mouvement veut
aussi soutenir une politique forte en
faveur des jeunes 14 millions de jeunes
Européens seraiit sans formation ni
qualification il y a une mesure phare
que l'Union européenne veut porter pour
la question de l'emploi des jeunes
puisque le taux de chômage des jeunes
dans des pays dépasse les 50 % en Grèce
en Espagne en Bulgarie voilà donc il
nous annonce une nouvelle mesure une
garantie jeune une espèce de RSA jeune à
Revenu Minimum jeunesse 433 € donc on
appréciera le le geste en terme de de
qualité de vie et puis derrière surtout
la contradiction c'est que c'est un plan
de 8 milliards d'euros or même les
instan européennes le Sénat français qui
a fait un rapport l'an dernier montre
qu'il faudrait 21 milliards euh pour
pour du coup avoir une réelle ambition
de politique d'emploi des jeunes au
niveau européen les communistes se sont
rallés au groupe de la Gauche Unitaire
groupe qui dispose de 5 députés français
dont en île-defance Patrick Le Yar
candidat lui aussi à sa succession alors
que beno amont l'a fermé tout au long de
la semaine nous sommes allés rencontrer
l'Inspecteur d'Académie pour savoir si
la réforme des rythmes scolaires se
mettrait bien en place dès ce mois de
septembre il répond dans ce sujet de
Catherine zulato et de Patrick Chac de
dixmud à l'opposition d'un nombre
grandissant de communes
dans les ivelines 240 communes sont
concernées par le changement de rythme
scolaire l'appliquent déjà depuis 2013 à
ce jour 198 projets ont été déposés sur
le bureau de l'inspecteur académique et
pour les 34 autres communes qui n'ont
pas encore rendu leur copies le temps
presse la date butoire a été fixée au 6
juin pour toutes les villes et même pour
celles qui freinent à appliquer la
réforme car dans le département du
ministre de l'Éducation benoî hon pas
question de transiger
communes bien puisque ça se décide au
niveau national qu'il est pas question
de moratoire le ministre a rappelé
encore récemment que on aurait à la
rentrée des textes qui s'appliquent par
conséquent les horaires des écoles
devraient répondre au principe de base
semaine de 24h 5 demi jour et travailler
la ville de plaisir a déjà annoncé
qu'elle n'appliquerait pas la réforme
des rythmes scolaires trop coûteuse à
mettre en place d'autres communes comme
morpa et lancour ou barci réclament un
moratoire sur la question et si cela
coince toujours c'est l'inspecteur
d'académie qui fixera les nouveaux
horaires à mettre en place ce que je
compte faire c'est prendre le
dénominateur le plus commun au
département et je peux le dire dès à
présent il est simple d'ailleurs je je
l'ai répété à chaque fois que nécessaire
ce qu'on retrouve le plus c'est un
fonctionnement à 5 demi-journée mercredi
matin compris et pour les horaires des 4
après-midis restantes en réalité un une
organisation suivante un quart d'heure
de moins dans la pause méridienne et une
demi-heure de moins en fin d'après-midi
autrement dit ça vous donne des horaires
qui vous font terminer à 16h au lieu de
16h30 tout d'abord j'espère ne pas avoir
à le faire j'espère que
Infiné une idée d'organisation horaire
sera retenu par par par les communes qui
qui demeurent un dernier conseil
départemental d'éducation nationale se
tiendra vers le 20 juin des courriers
vont être à nouveau envoyés aux communes
pour leur préciser les assouplissements
proposés par le nouveau décret des
communes qui peuvent demander à
expérimenter pendant un 2 ou 3 ans la
réforme cela suffira-t-il à convaincre
les élus les plus réfractaires une
course contre le temps
s'engage prochain journal en direct
lundi 18h avec notamment les premières
images des Bleus en pleine préparation
du Mondial brésilien il s'installe dans
les yvlin à clerfontaine nous partirons
aussi un petit peu plus loin à CAN en
partenariat avec Radio sensation à la
rencontre d'Iv Linois comédien
réalisateur ou encore danur excellent
weekend sur TVfil pour vos loisirs vos
idées sorties vous avez rendez-vous avec
Catherine
zulato